t-series is just a few subscribers away
Red Alert red alert
I'm calling upon my last trick I have up
my sleeve I didn't think it would come
to this but I guess I have no choice the
one thing that can stop t-series book
review you noticed how as soon as I
stopped doing book reviews sorry about
that by the way T's series two sways out
of nowhere and took over but no I
realize now in the eleventh hour what I
must do
I must review books again that's
whatever one wants that's what will stop
T series it's never been so clear to me
I can't believe I realized it just now
book time the first book well I read a
lot of books but I wanted to select the
ones that I really really loved there's
three of them but I want to talk about
and hopefully you'll check them out as
well the first one is the Master and
Margarita written by Nick Nicola Mikhail
Bulgakov it was written during the
Soviet Union regime and during that time
I didn't know this but atheism was sort
of forced upon the population it was
forced in schools and people were
generally harassed into becoming
atheists so this novel is sort of an
answer to that a lot of Russian books
I've read so far our features themes
around Christianity but I think it's
safe to say I never read a book like
this it's a black satire it's a black
satire comedy around Christianity it's
very weird but I really loved it
ironically mikail the author burned the
first version of this book because he
thought he would never make it as a
writer writing a story like this during
this time and
he wasn't wrong because when he actually
finished it 10 years later he died
shortly after so it's nothing funny
about that
and he wasn't published until 26 years
after that so it took a while but it was
recognized as a masterpiece and it
really is the story follows a mysterious
character who visits a group of writers
sitting in a park during an autumn
afternoon and this mysterious character
is a professor in black magic these
group of writers are obviously curious
who he is and they suspicious that he
might be a spy and he gets mistaken for
one this mysterious character is the
devil reincarnated and named in the in
the book Vohland all the writers are
atheists and Bolin describes the second
setting of the story which in Jerusalem
during the Pontius Pilate trials
everyone knows about this the the trial
is about the execution of Jesus the
writers almost say it's possible that
it's never happened it's possible that
Jesus never existed and boland sort of
smugly describes his event as if he was
actually there which is obviously
impossible bolon also predicts that one
of the writers head will come off in an
accident and this of course gets brushed
off but later becomes true and get
witnessed by one of the other writers
Yvonne Yvonne goes absolutely crazy
trying to pursue boland trying to
capture him in absolute madness
absurdity and comedy I love reading this
part it gets even better from there The
Devil's midnight ball is wasn't one of
my favorite parts of anything I read in
a while it's it's just fantastic so I
will just end it there but Micaela
the author of The Master and Margarita
he used to be a playwright so it makes
the writing very visual I can really see
all the characters and mannerism and the
humor in front of me it really feels
like you were there when you read it and
which really works well for the comedy
as well I laughed
a lot of times reading this book and all
this has really put together in a
masterful story it's a story that blends
history with the author's own stories
that he he lived through and his own
strides it's a perfect balance I think
of good and evil and I really really
loved it it was actually recommended by
one of you guys so I read one of the
comments saying in another book review
saying oh I think you're really gonna
love this book and you were right so
thank you very much the master margarita
five out of five thank you for
suggesting an actual good book the next
book I want to talk about it as Japanese
death poems and haiku what is it called
it's a really long title Japanese deaf
poems written by Zen monks and haiku
poets on the verge of death that may
sound very depressing to read but for me
I thought it was very uplifting I'm very
fascinated by the Eastern view or the
eastern Asian view of death as a Swedish
person it's almost a taboo subject it's
something that I grew up you don't
really talk about and I think that's
probably for a lot of people who has
least watches this video which I think
makes it just even lonelier and scarier
to think of that I don't think it's a
healthy approach and the Japanese view
is more of a it's something death is
something that's part of life one of my
favorite quotes from a book another
great book I read actually I recommend
in the region would by Murakami death is
not the opposite of life but an innate
part of it by living our lives we
nurture death anyhow this view of death
is deeply rooted in Japan and Japanese
culture through death poems or just say
as their call that sounds funny and its
origin comes from Zen Buddhism and the
first documented Zhu se is from Prince
Tatsu in 1686 but just like still
occurring today I find out about deaf
poems from one of my favorite writers
Yukio Mishima and I was just so
fascinated by the fact that that's an
actual thing
a small night storm blows saying falling
is the essence of a flower preceding
those who hesitate to put it simply it's
a poem written at the time
that but sometimes they're written even
before sort of as you write a will for
example haiku is a form of poetry you're
probably already familiar with it
follows the five seven five syllable
count
vashu world famous Japanese poet who
defined this style of writing where you
count the syllables of the poem his deaf
poems reads as falling ill on a journey
my dreams go wandering over withered
fields haiku is often focus on the
transient of things thus often reflects
on nature bringing in the sadness of
leaves falling from the cherry blossom
because they don't last very long for
example here's one written by Beynon now
spring has come into my world farewell
so the book starts off with Zen Buddhism
which it's actually my favorite part of
the book I didn't think I would enjoy it
I kind of wanted to just jump to the
Hyksos but it just features incredible
stories of Zen Buddhists or masters that
died sitting upright and right after
they finished their last brush strokes
of their poem I don't know if that's
true or not but it just sounds it sounds
badass and I like the idea that there's
actual records of this badass Munk movie
cliche that you see it actually has some
merit to it the book features around 300
haikus some are funny some are sad some
are strange
I'll read some more examples I wish to
die in spring beneath the cherry
blossoms while the springtime moon is
full written by Saigon here's another
one I liked death poems are merit
delusion death is death this one's
written by by psyche the journey west a
way that all would travel flower-filled
west is said to be where the paradise is
in I don't know when they believe in
their dying with the regret is seen as a
bad thing to carry when you're passing
over to to the paradise
this poem is a perfect example of a
haiku because it brings in something
personal mixed with nature another one
for example I long for people then again
I load them end of autumn it's almost
comical isn't it how can we fit nature
in there and a bottom but I really do
love haiku I think it's a it's a perfect
way to really describe an emotion I'd
really like the idea of bringing
something over bringing structure to
something abstract of a mixing left and
right brain mixing art with logic for
example having the the set of rules of
how a poem should be and now I think
that's what really makes them good as
well so I wrote a poem myself heritage
if you want him autumn moon shines
bright a lonely red leaves falls down
your mom gave no I'm just kidding okay
at ending road ahead I should travel
back home soon forever sunset the way
the Japanese language works it's
obviously different because the
syllables are are much more defined as
were the letters are cold goal Wow gosh
she and someone and so forth so it
doesn't really work the same way in
English and there's all kinds of
techniques that also doesn't really
translate so it's never gonna be
you can try and translate haikus to
English but it's never gonna be the same
thing obviously but I recommend writing
a haiku it's it's actually really easy
it's actually really fun all you need to
know is that it's five syllables first
line seven syllables live em in line and
then five syllables afterwards and it's
usually something personal mixed with
nature and
a passing moment described so why don't
you try it I wouldn't give this book
higher than a four star rating
it is quite dense in the beginning it
felt like I didn't need to it also had a
strange structure to it which was kind
of annoying when reading it other than
that it's a great book it features a lot
of haikus that's never been translated
before so I really really loved it and I
remember commended to you even as much
as any other book I talked about today
next but dumb Keshawn yeah that's right
you never heard about this one everyone
knows about donkey Shawn but the
nobleman who read too many night stories
and decided to go on a knight's errand
hey even though that doesn't exist
anymore everyone knows about the story
of donkey shot who mixed up the
windmills with Dragons and fought them
anyway
but I think most of all everyone knows
danke Shon for its humor and for how
silly it is and and what a loveable
character is but and yes it is it is
very humorous but after reading it I
realized that it's so much more than
just that and I'm so glad I read it it's
my favorite piece of classical
literature that I have ever read it was
written in 1600 by Cervantes I don't
know I probably pronounced that wrong
and it's been described as the best
literary work ever written I've also
seen is described as unreadable there's
a lot of different versions of donkey
shot to make it more normal
I don't know I read I remember I read
donkey shot before but a stripped down
version of it but nothing really could
read the original the book is written in
a way where donkey shot seems like he's
an actual person that exists in the
world a terrible example would be kind
of like found horror movie clips to make
it seem real this is lost archives to
make it seem like oh yeah this is this
is a real story that actually took place
in donkey shot is a real person
in the second half of the second part of
the book Cervantes is even himself
mentioned in the story because of course
the first book has already come out and
donkey shot is now famous and donkey
shot reacts to other people reacting to
donkey shot which is hilarious as well
so it's
it's really funny and bizarre thing but
anyway the story also of course follows
not just donkey shot but he's famous and
loyal squire sancho panza who joins
donkey shot in the promise of becoming a
governor one day
Sancho had great relief to donkey Shawn
because he sort of questions his ideas
and his sanity and all these random
insane inter fair interactions that
donkey shot goes through when in his
pursuit of knights-errant virtue and all
that because donkey shot believes
everything he's reading in books so he
treats the whole world as if that's the
case and anything that sort of
challenges that idea and goes against
that idea he blames on one way or
another it could be that oh it's a
wizard sage cast a spell on me so I'm
under under illusions and that's why
that's why I see it for no one else does
what makes this funny or I think at
least what makes this work is that
donkey shot is actually completely
reasonable as a person the way he
justifies all these things happening and
the way he justifies his action is
completely reasonable you realize he's
not an idiot he's not a pool and he can
suede Sancho Panza to to follow him and
do what he wants him to do and he
believes it himself 100% as well that's
the thing but of course other people
don't believe donkey shot and whatever
ideas he has and he becomes a mockery Oh
for them as well the fact that donkey
shot wholeheartedly believe is it it
makes it really sad it's a really sad
story in a lot of ways I think a lot of
people can probably relate to as at
least when you were younger wanting to
do something noble wanting to do
something greater but as you grow older
you you sort of give up on that idea I
mean everyone does obviously but not
donkey shot and this story tells tells
of that tale and you can really only
love him for him donkey shot and Sancho
Panza really are legendary characters
I I miss them it's really weird to say
that it's such a long book but it's the
it's the longest book I've read but it's
also the longest book I've ever enjoyed
and honestly I can't wait to reread it I
could go on more but there's really no
point it is it is quite hard at some
points and I would lie every lying say
if I thought it was like the easiest
read I ever had but it's 100% worth it
so check it out if you're interesting
check out all these books donkey shot
five out of five beautiful I'm so glad I
read it now for next book review I
wanted to mention a book that you guys
can read and we can discuss it in next
book next month if I do a book review
when I do a book review it will be the
woman in the dunes by a Cobra Abin I
don't know if that's how it's pronounced
kebab has been described as the Casca of
Japan it's a pretty short story so holy
[ __ ] I forgot to mention the book it has
some very strong sexual parts in it I
guess this is a trigger warning I
probably should have realized before I
recommended this but anyone can pick
this up and read it in I don't know a
week or two and it's a concept that I
think it's a interesting to discuss so
if you're looking for something to read
check that out and I'll talk about it in
the next month as always if you have
recommendations for me I always find
that interesting I've also created a
subreddit where you guys can discuss as
well and interact and I will take part
from that and reviews and ideas in the
next book review so hopefully we can
have a more of a dialogue going because
I felt like that was what was missing I
felt a bit discouraged doing book
reviews because it felt like no one is
actually cared or or interacted with it
or read the books but I'm told now that
a lot of people actually did which i
think is really cool I feel so will
fault myself because I think in this
pursuit with t-series I've been to focus
on the numbers and just pushing that
narrative which has been fun but I also
kind of miss just doing whatever I feel
like or whatever
I actually have a more personal interest
in so anyway that's it that's it for
book review I hope you guys enjoyed I
know these are very long and very
different but I hope it's fun anyway see
you guys tomorrow good bye